A novel virus causes panic, stinging insects
swarm America, and riots in the streets pit
the people vs. police — it happened in 2020,
and "The Simpsons" knew about it all in 1993.
"Yoo-hoo!"
Cartoon Network's "Johnny Bravo" followed the
buff blond womanizer through various exploits,
adventures and mishaps in one of
the best kids' shows of the 1990s.
"If Santa doesn't get these letters by tonight,
I might not get all those
free presents I asked for!"
In the episode "Chain Gang Johnny,"
which aired on April 27, 2001,
Johnny goes to the movies with his acquaintance
Carl. The two get into an argument over the film,
and if you look to Carl's side, you'll
notice an image of a building on fire.
As the scene pans over, we see the words
"Coming Soon" plastered on the poster.
"Oh, you will pay for this."
Seeing how the episode aired less than five
months before September 11, 2001, some have
come to see the cartoon as an eerie vision of
the future. The actual answer is likely a bit
anticlimactic. Buildings on fire are nothing new
to the world of action movies, and it's likely the
image merely functioned as an homage to something
like "The Towering Inferno." It's also worth
pointing out there's only one building depicted
in the advertisement instead of the two buildings
that would make for the Twin Towers. So if you
were thinking this was a real prediction, well…
"Close." "Nice try, though."
In addition to "Johnny Bravo," "The
Simpsons" has also found itself at
the center of "9/11 prediction" theories
thanks to one scene from a classic episode.
"Stupid city. What the hell is this thing?"
In Season 9's "The City of New York vs. Homer
Simpson," the family decides to travel to the Big
Apple to retrieve Homer's car. When discussing
how they could possibly afford such a trip,
Lisa holds up a magazine promotion, saying
how there are rides to New York for just $9.
Right next to the price is the
silhouette of the Twin Towers.
It almost looks as though the cover
reads "9 11." It's enough to make
you want to get a hold of the Simpsons
writers, and ask them how they knew.
"Here's a better idea: You give me your address,
and I'll write to you." "Okay, just
send it to Jesus, care of the Pentagon."
It seems like all it takes to make a "9/11
prediction" is two towers that look similar and
an airplane. That's precisely what you have with
the classic Bugs Bunny cartoon, "Falling Hare."
In it, Bugs goes toe-to-toe with a Gremlin on the
side of his plane. It's up to Bugs to navigate the
vessel to a safe landing, which becomes all
the more difficult when he finds himself in
the midst of a massive city. At one point, the
rascally rabbit approaches two tall buildings
extremely close to one another. At the
last second, before Bugs would make impact,
he turns the plane on its side so that he
safely flies between the two structures.
Considering this cartoon came out decades
before the World Trade Center was built,
we're thinking this is less of a "prediction,"
and more of a weird thing to notice
while you're watching old cartoons.
"The Simpsons" has seemingly predicted everything
from Donald Trump's presidency to
Richard Branson going to space.
But one of the show's most spot-on predictions
came in the form of the Season 5 episode
"$pringfield (Or, How I Learned to Stop
Worrying and Love Legalized Gambling)."
"Legalized gambling is a bad idea. You
can build a casino over my dead body."
In the episode, Springfield
becomes its very own Atlantic City,
complete with a towering casino with live
entertainment. One of these shows is "The
Flamboyant Magic of Gunter and Ernst," in what is
a clear parody of performers Siegfried and Roy,
who had a long-running show in Las Vegas for
many years with their signature white tigers.
Gunter and Ernst also have a tiger by the
name of Anastasia, and after a moment,
when the tiger remembers what it was like
to live in the tranquility of the jungle,
it attacks the two performers. The
scene took on new life when in 2003,
Roy suffered severe injuries from a
tiger attack in real life. Fortunately,
he managed to pull through from the incident,
and the duo would go on to perform again.
"You know, we are having a party tonight."
Some cartoon predictions aren't super on the nose,
but they can still have a chilling
detail that makes you stop and say...
"Oh… my… god."
That's the case with a Season 8
episode of "American Dad!" where
Steve and his friends stumble upon a
downed plane. Once venturing inside,
they find a corpse clutching a script, which
just so happens to be for "Fast & Furious 7."
"Look, it's signed by Randy Scott Knobson, the guy
who wrote all the 'Fast and the Furious' movies!"
The guys are stoked to get a glimpse into
the future of the high-octane franchise,
but when viewing the episode today, it's hard
not to be reminded of Paul Walker's death,
whose final, posthumous film
role was in "Furious 7."
Walker died tragically in a car crash, eerily
reminiscent of the plane crash depicted in the
episode. As it just so happens, the scene the
friends read from the script heavily involves
Walker's character Brian O'Conner to make
the connection all the more heartbreaking.
It's pretty impressive when a cartoon
predicts a single aspect of the future.
It becomes downright bizarre when a single episode
contains multiple references to an entire year.
Season 4's "Marge in Chains" starts off
with virtually everyone in Springfield
coming down with a case of a mysterious
new disease known as the Osaka Flu.
"The dreaded Osaka Flu has hit Springfield
with over 300 cases now reported."
The novel disease spread from Japan
after some factory workers coughed
into a box on its way to Springfield.
Despite the fact this virus came from
Japan and coronavirus initially hailed
from China, many couldn't help but see
some parallels -- especially considering
how the rest of the episode plays out.
Later in the episode, the citizens of the small
town become panicked and turn toward Dr. Hibbert
for guidance. He tells them that he doesn't
have anything that can cure the outbreak,
and in an ensuing clash, people knock over
a box of killer bees. Bees aren't hornets,
but it still reminded people of the murder
hornets that briefly overtook headlines in 2020.
Eventually, the episode culminates in mass social
unrest, with protesters knocking down statues,
and facing off with police in the
streets. Gee, that feels familiar.
"This never would've happened
if Marge Simpson was here."
Kevin Spacey's fall from grace may have been a
little more predictable to people in Hollywood
than it was to the rest of the world. After
decades of critically-acclaimed performances,
the actor was accused by several men
of sexual harassment and assault,
sending his career into a nosedive. But
the news may not have been too surprising
for anyone who enjoyed watching
early episodes of "Family Guy."
In the season four episode "Don't Make Me
Over," Brian and Stewie make a wager, ultimately
resulting in Stewie running naked through
a mall shouting something weirdly specific.
"Help! I've escaped from Kevin
Spacey's basement. Help me!"
Apparently, "Family Guy" creator Seth
Macfarlane has a knack for identifying
sexual predators. Before Harvey Weinstein
was outed as a criminal sexual predator,
Macfarlane made a joke at the producer's
expense during an Oscar-related telecast.
After announcing the nominees for
Best Supporting Actress, he joked:
"Congratulations, you five ladies no longer have
to pretend to be attracted to Harvey Weinstein."
With that kind of batting average,
maybe Macfarlane should work less with
cartoons and lean into detective work.
"What have we got today, boys?" "Well, it
seems we've got a bit of a crime spree."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.